[موسيقى]
أجنبية
أعتقد أنه تمت تغطية 90 موضوعًا، لقد
كان برنامجًا قويًا للغاية،
قيادتنا، لدي
شيء مشترك وهو أن رئيسنا
ورئيس دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة هم
أشخاص عدوانيون للغاية ويركزون على النتائج،
لذا فهم  أضع نفسي
ونظيري أمام وزير التجارة على
أدواتهما، لذلك تعمل فرقنا على
مدار الساعة وآمل أنه
بحلول نهاية أبريل أه اعتبارًا من الشهر المقبل،
ستكون الإمارات العربية المتحدة بالفعل واحدة من
أفضل خمس قراءة  أنت تعرف
شركاء معينين لكينيا، لذا فنحن
نتاجر بالفعل ولكن حجم تجارتنا
منخفض جدًا، كما تعلم نحن كذلك وأه تعلم أن 250
مليون دولار مجتمعة بحجم
ثلاثة معظم المواد الغذائية تميل
لصالح دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة، لذا فإن كينيا
أعتقد أن كل شيء يستفيد منه أكثر
من الإمارات العربية المتحدة، لكنها في الواقع
علاقة مربحة للجانبين أه بالنسبة لكينيا والإمارات العربية المتحدة،
ولكن على وجه الخصوص، لا يتعلق الأمر بالتجارة فحسب،
بل كإشارة
للاستثمار الضخم الذي نتوقع أن
تفتحه هذه الاتفاقية لدولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة
المستثمرين للاستثمار في كينيا والعكس
أيضًا على وجه الخصوص، نحن ننظر بالطبع إلى
المنتجات الزراعية وهي الأفوكادو
والمانجو والمكسرات، أفضل منتجاتنا
في العالم، أنت تعرف الشاي والقهوة لدينا
ولكن أيضًا لأننا
نحاول أيضًا تصنيعك  نعرف الكثير
ليس فقط عن المنتجات الطازجة ولكن أيضًا عن
المنتجات ذات القيمة المضافة التي تحاول الوصول إلى
قاعدة التصنيع في كينيا
والتي نأمل أيضًا أن تجد طريقها إلى
محلات السوبر ماركت في دبي والإمارات العربية المتحدة ودول مجلس التعاون الخليجي.
نعم،
نعم، نحن نجري مناقشات مع
حكومة الإمارات العربية المتحدة أه بالفعل الإمارات العربية المتحدة
هي مصدر رئيسي للنفط الخام
ومصفاة النفط الخام حتى الآن
للمنتجات المكررة أه نحن أدنوك لاعب جاد أم
تعرفه في هذا السوق رامكو من
السعودية أه لذلك أعتقد أن ما نحاوله  ما يجب
فعله الآن هو محاولة تبسيط تلك
العلاقة العاملة بالفعل أه محاولة
تقديم الائتمان للمنتجات النفطية
لأننا نواجه هذه
المشكلة مثل معظم البلدان الأفريقية
فيما يتعلق بالنقد الأجنبي، لذلك
نحاول إعادة هيكلة الطريقة التي
نتعامل بها مع النفط  بين دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي وكينيا
حتى نتمكن من تخفيف الضغط
على عملتنا الأجنبية ولكن أيضًا أن
تكون كينيا بمثابة بوابة عبر
مناطقنا الاقتصادية الخاصة في مومباسا وإيران
لشركات دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي الكبرى مثل
أرنو أرامكو التي تستخدم كينيا كنقطة انطلاق
بوابة أو
كنقطة لوجستية للصور لتوريدها
لبقية أفريقيا، لذا فهي لا
تزود السوق الكينية فحسب، بل تراها أيضًا
تبنيها. تعد كينيا
نقطة توزيع لبقية أفريقيا
الأجنبية،
فنحن نبحث عن شركات من دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي.
الذين يتطلعون إلى ذلك لديهم
نهج توسعي يتمحور حول أفريقيا والشيء
المذهل هو أن
الإمارات العربية المتحدة تسير على هذا المسار، فنحن نتحدث
مع الشركات التي تعمل في مجال الطاقة المتجددة، ونتحدث
مع شركات الاتصالات،
ونتحدث مع
الشركات في  العقارات وقد
أبدى معظمهم اهتمامًا كبيرًا بالاستثمار
في كينيا وفي إفريقيا،
كما تعلمون أن إحدى فترات
استراتيجية الرؤية 2030 في المملكة العربية السعودية
هي أنك تعرف توسعًا عالميًا
لأعمالهم ونحن  لدينا
اهتمام هائل للغاية من الشركات السعودية
للاستثمار في كينيا، لذلك أنا
متحد جدًا، كما تعلمون،
أرحب بالكثير من الشركات السعودية
في مجال الزراعة والابتكار في مجال النفط
والغاز والبتروكيماويات في المصانع
الأجنبية
ولكن في  من حيث الأشخاص ورأس
المال البشري وتنمية الشباب
وحماسهم، إنه أمر
لا يصدق، كما تعلمون، العودة إلى
السعودية، بلدي، بيتي الثاني وهو
نوع من الجسم الكامل كما تعلمون
لأنه يشعر بالحنين لأنني كنت في
السعودية.  أعرف أنه في أواخر التسعينيات
ويعمل هناك مصرفي وأعود
الآن وأقول للشباب الذين قمت بتعليمهم بشكل
إيجابي للغاية كشخص عمل
في هذه المنطقة والآن
يدير كينيا ويحاول أن تعرف
حقًا محاولة التأثير على
بقية  التي مر بها يسوع
ومحاولة تطبيق نفس الشيء معًا،
شكرًا لك